horas después de que brasil reportará la
primera muerte fuera del continente
africano de un paciente con viruela del
mono españa ha anunciado el primer
fallecido en europa en este brote
declarado por la oms como emergencia de
salud pública de importancia
internacional hace menos de una semana
aunque el ministerio de sanidad no ha
dado información sobre la víctima con
estas dos personas la cifra de
fallecidos por viruela símica asciende a
al menos 7 en el mundo entero españa es
el segundo país con más número de
contagios con casi 4.300 le supera tan
sólo eeuu que roza los 5.000 contagios
aunque hay que tener en cuenta que el
país americano tiene 6 veces más
población que españa de todas las
personas contagiadas sólo 64 son mujeres
en españa' y la edad media de contagio
es de 37 años en la mayoría de los
positivos la relación sexual fue la vía
de contagio
la campaña de vacunación preventiva
empezó en españa el 21 de julio sin
embargo las dosis disponibles unas 5.300
no son suficientes para cubrir en la
población diana de esta vacuna
cualquier persona entre los 18 y 45 años
que mantenga relaciones sexuales
consideradas de riesgo sin embargo el
ministerio de sanidad ha anunciado que
la semana que viene llegarán otras siete
mil dosis